So now some of the problems with,
with the Marxist perspective seems to be
that victimhood,
their sense of enhanced victimhood tends
to produce an intense sense of
resentment and that's a very bad idea
because resentment is a very toxic and
violent emotion.
It's also very ungrateful,
which is one of the things I would
really say about,
especially the radical left student
types,
especially at Ivy League universities.
I mean it's really quite a spectacle to
see people at places like Yale come out
and agitate as a consequence of the
realization of their own oppression when
by any reasonable standard,
current or historical,
they're probably in the top one,
100th of a percent at perhaps better
than that of all the people who have
ever lived anywhere ever.
And so it really.
It's really.
It's really quite staggering to me that
the top point zero,
zero,
one percent can express their resentment
about the top point zero,
zero,
one percent in such strident terms
without noticing that exactly the same
claims of privilege apply to them by as
long as all you have to do is transform
the,
the bend in which you're doing the
privilege comparisons and that becomes
immediately self evident and you know
the fact that as Americans,
let's say,
or a North American since I'm a
Canadian,
that were staggeringly privileged
compared to the rest of the world,
is certainly a consequence of the of
what you might describe as the
arbitrariness of our political borders
and so,
but to forget that when you're claiming
a particular brand of oppression for
yourself seems to me to be very
ungrateful at the least and certainly
motivated,
let's say politically because I think it
justifies your expression of hatred for
those tiny fraction of people who are
still better off than you.
And also a degree of historical
ignorance.
That's absolutely staggering in its
magnitude and a complete indictment of
our education system,
which should be indicted in every
possible way,
so now the Marxists might claim to their
benefit,
let's say with this worldview of class
struggle as being the primary driver of
human history and the well off
socioeconomically because that's pretty
much the only way they define well off,
which is also something I take great
objection to because there's lots of
hierarchies in the world and there are
many important hierarchies and not all
of them can be reduced to socioeconomic
status by any stretch of the
imagination.
Imagine if you are 80 years old and you
had $20,000,000,
you know,
he might be perfectly happy to get rid
of all that money if you could be 18
again.
So it's.
And you know,
one of the best predictors of wealth in
North America is actually age because
you know,
young people haven't actually had much
time to make money,
whereas old people have had quite a bit
of time.
But the problem with being old enriches
that you're still old and that actually
turns out to be quite a serious problem
because no matter how rich you are,
you eventually die and so the money is
the money has a very delimited if
limited effect with regards to
addressing the fundamental problems of
the suffering of life and we know
perfectly well from the empirical
perspective that once you have enough
money so that the bill collectors aren't
chasing you around.
Essentially something like the
beginnings of a middle class existence
or maybe the upper end of the working
class than additional money has
absolutely no bearing whatsoever on your
psychological wellbeing.
And that's actually an indication of the
limitations of material comfort.
Let's say as a medication for the.
For the suffering that's attendant on
life.
It's another thing that's very weak
about the Marxists and I think very
interestingly contradictory because
they're very anti capital in their
structure,
but they're so damn materialistic that
it's absolutely mind boggling because
the Marxists are actually more convinced
that money is useful than most
capitalists.
As far as I can tell.
Because they believe that that money is
in fact the solution to all life's
problems.
The problem is is that just the right
people don't have the money and I think
that's a staggeringly naive perspective
because there's many,
there's many problems in life that money
just cannot solve and there's a fair
number of them and that it actually
makes worse.
So anyways,
having said all that,
you could also still make the case.
I used to work for a Socialist Party in
Canada when I was a kid about six
[inaudible] time.
I was 14 till the time I was about 17
before I figured out what was wrong,
not so much with socialism per se,
but with ideology per se,
and I actually admired the socialist
leaders that I had the fortune to be
introduced to because at that point they
were very much a voice for the working
class.
A lot of union leaders and people like
that,
you know,
so they're classic Democratic Socialists
on the Labor end of the distribution and
it's absolutely necessary for labor and
the working class to have a political
voice.
Something the Democrats might keep in
mind.
So when maybe they wouldn't lose their
elections quite so frequently now,
I really think it's appalling,
you know,
because it's necessary for the working
class to have a political voice.
So.
And to have that transformed into
identity politics is a real catastrophe.
Anyways.
I think that the people that I met,
many of them were genuinely concerned
with the problems of the working class
and you know,
more power to them.
And so I think there are people on the
left who,
who genuinely are trying to make a
difference for people who could use a,
a fair shot at opportunity in life.
But at the same time I noticed that a
tremendous number of the,
of especially the lower and worker,
a party worker per protester types were
more peevish and resentful than
goodhearted and kind.
And it was about that time that I came
across George Orwell's famous critique
of left wing thinking and in the UK in a
book called road to Wigan Pier,
where he basically made the claim that
the socialists that he knew,
especially the middleclass ones,
didn't give a damn about the poor.
They just hated the rich.
And that's,
I mean,
that is something we're thinking about
for a very long period of time because
hatred actually turns out to be a very
powerful motivation,
you know,
and if you think about the sorts of
things that happened in the Soviet Union
and all these places that were supposed
to be workers paradises,
if you look at the outcome and you had
to infer whether it was goodness of
heart and kind heartedness and care for
the working man that produced the
genocides or outright bitter,
resentful,
resentment,
and hatred,
it's a lot easier to draw a causal path
from the negative emotion to the
outcome.
Then from the positive kind hearted
benevolence to that,
you just don't get gulags out of
benevolence.
That's just not how it works.
So I think the bloody historical
evidence is clear.
Um,
although I have read the most
convoluted,
pathological,
pathetic,
twisted rationalizations of what
happens,
stay installing this Russia that you
could possibly manufacture.
It's as if on a stack of corpses that
would reach halfway to the moon isn't
enough evidence for the pathology of a
certain form of belief.
So some people can't be convinced by
anyone's death,
but their own,
I suppose.